good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about five ways to find
your soulmate this is what you want to
reach out this week and remind you what
you already know and that is no matter
how stressful your life can be whether
it be the economy or kids or your
business ultimately it makes you feel
alive is love love and passion together
we're incredibly passionate about this
subject and you know love is something
that you certainly just don't take for
granted and something that you
consciously create every moment every
day of your life the correct mindset to
attract soulmate is not to look for the
right person but to become the right
person so never ask what kind of person
I want to attract in my life ask
yourself what kind of person I want to
be and then when you become those
qualities and the soulmate will show up
to reflect those qualities because every
relationship is a mirror and if you
don't like what you're seeing in the
mirror then you don't fight with the
mirror or break it you change the
reflection by changing yourself you know
most people think they need to know the
right thing to say or the right strategy
or the place to go and strategy is
important in life but strategy's not
usually what holds people back from
getting a great relationship it's a
belief system in their head that limits
them it's a story
honestly those stories I remember
wouldn't be right before we met I was
thinking I was scared and thinking
honestly I wanted to be alone and want
to live on my own and wasn't looking for
a relationship and then in a moment God
intervened and I think just at that time
even though I wasn't ready or prepared
God was and life showed up and it was
one of those divine moments and so
sometimes our fears and her stories to
remain open to what's possible creates a
pathway to be able to find enough yeah I
was in the same place I'd end your
relationship in the last thing I wanted
was another relationship I associated so
much pain to it I had so much more a joy
and happiness with my kids and joint
happiness with my work and my mission
but really the only being that keeps you
from getting what you want is the story
about why you can't have it all right
you don't have it and most common
stories are things like you know all the
good ones are gone for you know or you
know I'm not ready or I have too much
time for work later stage of life
relationship such a painful it's not
worth the time I'm set in my ways I love
my life my work is my first there's just
so many stories and Staffing's that we
create that prevent us from the
possibility of love so you gotta just
first maybe analyze what's your story
and find a new story new opportunity and
what will help you to change your
stories the third thing we always look
at breakthroughs in life you change
everything in a moment takes maybe a new
strategy but usually a new story a new
belief a new opening it also makes a new
state a new emotional state if you're
all uptight about relationship and your
is this the right one the level of
tension in your body pushes people away
from you
you know or if you're thinking
relationships not for me is throw off an
aura it makes people not be attracted to
you then you wonder why you know people
aren't approaching Illium most people
has nothing to do with what they're
physically like you know people that are
physically beautiful but they're ugly
and they're state they're angry they're
frustrated they're bitter if you change
your state you start to change
everything in your story it's amazing to
me how much time people spend worrying
about lamenting about their relationship
with somebody else
they spend absolutely no time developing
a relationship with themselves so very
often people want to be with somebody
because they don't want to be by
themselves well here's a question if you
don't want to be with you why does
anybody else want to be with you what do
you look like from the inside out do you
have a clear mind do you have a sweet
spirit do you have an open heart have
you abandoned you have you abandoned
your dreams have you abandoned your
gifts when was the last time you had an
intimate conversation with you when was
the last time you took you out for a
good evening when was the last time you
enjoyed being home in your PJs with you
doing something fun oh we live in a
world where we expect something or
someone outside of ourselves to make us
happy remember the only relationship
that you can ever have is a reflection
of the one you're having with yourself
so if you want somebody really good and
wonderful in your life start with you
build that relationship and let's see
what happens if you want something to
change are the things that you look at
the change change the way that you look
at things that begins by examining not
only who you are today but what made you
that way what started those triggers
what prompted those responses and you're
gonna find that most of those things you
either learn through modeling or
conditioning yeah all right and also put
your toxic relationships behind you
because I can make so many people so
bitter and they keep talking about that
bad relationship which they chose I mean
we gotta admit that we choose those
relationships yeah I had a lady I was
doing a lecture at one point and this
lady says well the last four men I've
dated they were this and they were that
and I said well dear you know the one
thing they all had in common you so when
I told her yeah amazing faith
yeah so when I told her that you know
she set there with her mouth open and
what I had to let her know is that if
you want something different why don't
you make a fresh start in quit recycling
old people situations and circumstance
yeah my husband has a line that I always
quote because it's it's not all why I
married him but it's a lot of why I
married him is this line he said a
woman's place is in the kitchen with her
feet up drinking a glass of wine
watching her husband cook her a meal
we're never beaten up treating watching
her husband cook her a meal and that is
I just that's it I come home and he
loves to cook
and I sit down and this is why I like it
I almost want to cry but he'll just
stand there and he'll be like I'm gonna
make a big curry I'm gonna make cuz he
loves to do these big Mama's cooking
things his Brazilian but his mother was
Italian so he loves like slow cooking
and then got to invite me to use a glass
of wine oh you you are welcome and he'll
pour me a glass of wine and he'll say
now darling tell me everything Wow what
happened today tell me and and I'll just
sit there with my feet I'm like how did
I win this life Wow
how did I win this life and and I was
talking about this with a friend and she
said because you blossomed into this
sort of person who attracted a man like
that and you learned how to treat
yourself so well on your own that when
someone came along who treated you well
you finally recognized what that feels
like because you've been doing it to
yourself the whole time
hallelujah so I noticed him I was like
oh he treats me the way I treat me now
so yeah let's go for me finally my soul
mate was easy just go out salsa dancing
you
so thank you guys so much for watching
let me know what you think of the video
let me know which clips were most
impactful to you what changes are gonna
make in your life as a result of
watching it leave in the comments below
if you have found your soul mate I'm
curious to find out how you guys met
leave in the comments doing a little
personal today I'd love to see the
reactions come through thank you guys so
much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
you know someone earlier asked us about
how do you start dating again especially
a middle-aged mm-hmm well the first
thing is this if you want to convert an
idea to a plan it's a four-letter word
and not that word it's date yeah you you
put a date on it the second thing is go
to the places where someone's
personality is incidental to the place
that you're going meaning if you want
someone that takes good care of
themselves go to the gym go you know go
and if you want someone that's nurturing
and empathetic and compassionate find
somebody that volunteers their time in a
social service situation or something
you're starting off where you have
evidence
remember evidence that this person
possesses that which you seek the great
Indian boy to Gore once said love is not
a mere sentiment it is the ultimate
truth at the heart of creation which
means that your essential state is love
what distorts that is that we look
outside for love not realizing that the
love that we experience outside is a
reflection of the love we have for our
deepest self and when I say deeper self
I don't mean your ego which is not
yourself it that's a socially induced
hallucination I mean your soul which is
beyond your self image your true self
your true self is love and so in your
actions in the world if you just ask
yourself if I made this choice am i
loving myself if I really loved myself
would I make this choice now that means
everything from how you speak to a
person how you take care of your body
how you talk to your parents or your
children how you put food in your body
before you do that ask yourself if I
love myself would I do this and then
intuitively choose the right on
and stop looking for the right person
because the right person is only a
reflection of who you are instead of
looking for the right person become the
right person so when people show you
please understand the truth of them and
yourself and do not waste your time with
people who have shown you that they
really mean no good for you Maya has
another phrase do not let yourself be
surrounded by people who will Peck you
to death like a duck she says if you
allow yourself to be around people who
show you who they are and you refuse to
believe it they will each time they
enter into your space take a little
piece of your soul